la commission de vérité réconciliation
du Canada formulé en 2015 des
recommandations touchant le
développement économique des membres des
Premières Nations du pays lutter contre
la discrimination veillée à un accès
équitable aux emplois et à la formation
impliquez les collectivités autochtones
aussi dans les projets économiques alors
en cette journée nationale nous avons eu
envie de faire le point avec une
entreprise Mélanie Paul qui est
conférencière également bonsoir madame
Paul
bonsoir madame Morin alors dites-moi 7
ans plus tard est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que les choses bougent en
matière de développement économique pour
les Premières Nations au Québec
oui effectivement on sent un vin de
changement depuis plusieurs années
particulièrement je dirais dans les deux
trois dernières années
entre autres avec les différents
événements qui sont arrivés je veux dire
les événements malheureux les
découvertes justement en lien avec les
pensionnats qu'est-ce qui est arrivé
aussi à Madame Joyce et chacuan c'est
des moi je dirais que c'est un éveil de
conscience de la population que ça le
crée au niveau économique plusieurs
structures qui se mettent en place aussi
depuis plusieurs années mais ces
événements-là je dirais ont créé un pont
ou une ouverture
qui ont ouvert le dialogue en fait à
aller plus loin avec les Premières
nations puis effectivement là que ce
soit au niveau des commissions de
développement économique des Premières
nations ou des entreprises les gens se
structure pour mieux répondre
aux besoins économiques de leur
communauté puis de mieux collaborer
aussi en partenariat avec les gens
au niveau québécois pour participer au
développement économique puis
je dirais
au développement économique dans
différents secteurs d'activités au
marché de l'emploi aussi quand on parle
de pénurie de main d'oeuvre on dit faut
intégrer davantage les gens des
Premières nations est-ce que vous sentez
que ça commence à changer ça l'approche
des employeurs
oui effectivement les employeurs moi je
le sens je le vois aussi à travers les
différentes formations les différents
des différentes approches que les gens
ont envie d'apprendre justement à mieux
connaître les Premières nations voir
comment la clientèle des Premières
nations pourrait devenir aussi un bassin
de main-d'oeuvre intéressant pour eux
j'ai eu la chance de participer à un
guide ou un rapport justement sur
l'intégration de la main d'oeuvre en
compagnie du Conseil du patronat du
Québec puis effectivement
il y a de plus en plus de d'ouverture en
ce sens là puis il y a de plus en plus
de gens aussi qui qui sont formés chez
les Premières nations parce que
longtemps les gens le taux des
décrochage les Premières nations étaient
quand même à prélever maintenant on voit
que les gens se rendent plus loin dans
leurs études les jeunes vont de plus en
plus loin au niveau cégep au niveau de
des universités aussi donc ça ça crée
aussi un bassin de main d'oeuvre
intéressant pour les gens je dis souvent
aussi aux entrepreneurs
qui désire se rapprocher des communautés
que oui il y a un bassin de main
d'oeuvre qui formait c'est facile pour
ces gens-là je dirais de se trouver des
emplois parce que il y a quand même
plusieurs disponibilités d'emploi là où
ça devient un peu plus difficile c'est
la clientèle des Premières nations qui
est un peu plus éloignée du marché du
travail qui ont besoin d'être accompagné
à différents niveaux c'est un peu ce que
le guide faisait ressortir au niveau des
différents défis je dirais sociaux et
autres qui fait que ces gens-là sont
plus éloignés du marché du travail et
ont un intérêt mais il y a des étapes à
franchir avant d'arriver à l'emploi à
temps plein je dirais qu'est-ce que des
employeurs peuvent faire justement
concrètement pour faciliter l'arrivée
sur le marché du travail de ces gens qui
sont un peu plus éloignés qui ont
peut-être pas de formation comme
normalement le nécessiterait les postes
qui sont affichés
moi je dirais qu'il faut avoir un
ouverture puis peut-être regarder les
exigences aussi qu'on demande à l'entrée
de l'emploi c'est sûr qu'il y a des
types d'emplois qu'on peut pas je
voudrais diminuer nos exigences mais il
y a d'autres emplois par contre qu'on
peut se structurer souvent à l'interne
pour pouvoir former les gens à l'interne
ou je dirais transmettre justement la
connaissance ou l'expertise à l'interne
donc avoir une ouverture à ce niveau-là
ça peut aider beaucoup nous c'est ce
qu'on a fait régulièrement dans nos
entreprises je dirais à compétence égale
en priorise toujours les Premières
nations puis quand il faut former les
gens mais on s'organise souvent avec des
centres de formation professionnelle
pour venir justement donner la formation
à l'interne de nos entreprises donc
qu'est-ce qui devrait y avoir plus de
stage d'apprentissage sur le milieu de
travail
c'est sûr que oui moi je pense que une
des caractéristiques des gens des
Premières nations c'est que les gens
sont visuels sont manuels un peu plus
les gens apprennent par je dirais par
visualisation souvent aussi donc d'être
jumelé à des gens dans un stage ça peut
être fastant un des éléments aussi qu'il
faut tenir compte c'est de créer des
liens de confiance de d'apprendre à
mieux se connaître aussi c'est important
de prendre le temps puis effectivement
en stage je pense que ça peut être une
belle porte d'entrée pour aider
justement à ce que les gens
apprennent à se connaître puis qui crée
des liens puis que ça soit plus facile à
l'intégration par la suite la campagne
électorale s'achève les élections lundi
avez-vous trouvé chez les parties des
engagements qui répondent à vos
préoccupations en matière de
réconciliation aussi en matière
d'entrepreneuriatomes
c'est sûr que oui il y a un an dans
chacun des parties de façon différente
maintenant
à chaque élection il y a toujours des
promesses est-ce que les actions et les
promesses sont tenues sauf un autre
chose moi je vous dirais ce qui est
important c'est oui les promesses mais
c'est beaucoup les actions qui vont
suivre de ça puis c'est pour apprendre
de passer aussi il faut voir qu'est-ce
que l'avenir nous réserve puis je dirais
faut aussi y aller avec les valeurs des
Premières nations c'est pas juste une
question de promesse ou d'action mais
est-ce que les valeurs de ce qui est
promis en lien avec l'environnement en
lien avec justement le partage des
ressources naturelles qui est un élément
important pour effectivement merci
beaucoup madame pod d'avoir été avec
nous
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI